Here at Stanford University, we're interested in learning...
...about how tiny things move objects much larger than themselves.
Using a special adhesive inspired by gecko toes,...
...our microrobots can move objects over 2,000 times their own weight.
The question is, like ants, can our robots work together...
...to accomplish great things?
After a series of experiments,...
...we found that the best way for robots to work together as a team...
...was to use a very long, very slow, but very steady winching gate,...
...like our team of microrobots here.
With near perfect teamwork and impressive individual strength,...
...this team of six MicroTugs weighing only 100 grams...
...move the author's unmodified 3,900-pound, 1,800-kilogram...
...car and driver, shown here at 20 times speed.